Now,
(audience applaud)
although it feels like "Friends" never went away.
Like there was all of "Friends",
it took a beat and then it started re-airing again.
And I feel like the cycle of "Friends"
is something that we've never been without.
And you must be getting hounded so much
about the reunion of "Friends",
which was delayed because of the pandemic.
But Oh my God, we've all been on the feeder of this
as if it's like life juice.
Yeah.
Well, we did the reunion and it's an unscripted
with lots of surprises,
and we all got together on Stage 24 at Warner Brothers
and that's the first time we've done that
since the show ended,
so it was very emotional and I just...
It was great.
Does it feel like there's been a gap in time
when you see everybody together on Stage 24?
Yeah.
I mean, we'll always have an incredible bond
that feels like we're like this.
Everybody's just so excited for this reunion.
Do they swear you to secrecy?
Honestly, I'm trying to think
of how do I answer a question without getting in trouble.
'cause I'll be just like yeah.
How do you talk about the "Friends Reunion"
without talking about the "Friends Reunion"?
(audience laughing)
Unscripted, reunion, Stage 24,
surprises.
That's all I got.
But thank you.
(audience laughing)
We're all looking so forward to that.
And, okay, so "Nine Months With Courtney Cox"
like this is the third season,
I just watched the trailer for season three,
which is out now and talking about pregnancy,
whether it was miscarriages
or what it takes for people to fight to get pregnant and IVF
and all of these experiences,
why did you feel compelled to tap into something
that is very private, quiet and not spoken about?
Well, originally how it started was my producing partners,
Ankle Entertainment had, through my agent,
sent a sizzle reel,
but I've watched the sizzle reel of "Nine Months"
and I was like, I called immediately.
I have to be involved in the show.
And the reason why is it's so honest,
everyone films themselves,
it's not scripted,
no one's telling you what to do
or how to behave.
They're just real.
And I think it's really important for people to know
that they're not alone.
I mean, we have every single walk of life.
We have couples, just a range with like a clip of it.
You're going to show, hopefully a teenage couple
that decided to have a child and they didn't plan it
but it's an incredible experience to watch.
And you pull for these people
and I'm really proud of it.
We actually have the clip you just mentioned.
Let's take a look.
Mary is pregnant.
You're 17, she's 16 and you're still in my house.
Do you realize that you are a young white young lady
that's about to give birth to a black child?
Mmh.
And are you ready for everything that comes with that?
When I found out I was pregnant with his baby,
that was definitely not the thought that came to mind.
The thought that comes into mind is just
this is terrifying,
I don't know how I'm going to do this
but I'm going to love my baby no matter what.
Well, I think you made such a brilliant choice
by making it such an intimate setting,
because you're just going to get an intimacy
that you won't get with a crew being there.
But what the heck is going on with "Scream",
I'm dying to know.
"Scream", this is the fifth one.
It's not Scream five though, this is "Scream".
These directors,
these guys are just the...
The directors are incredible,
they're making it absolutely, it's a new franchise.
It's scary,
it's just a new "Scream".
It's not a reboot, it's not a remake,
it's just a brand new launch.
I think it's going to be fantastic.
I'm so excited for it.
And you just took me back to being in Sonoma, California,
shooting the very first "Scream".
Oh my God.
Gosh, the opening of that movie.
I mean, if you guys haven't seen it
you have to say Drew in opening of "Scream"
it is one of the best performances ever.
You're unbelievable.
That means so much as a fellow alumni
of what became a gigantic franchise movie.
It was such an original script,
such a fresh concept,
and I'm so glad that it's come full circle
and long live "Scream".
I know, gosh, Kevin Williamson he was our writer
and he just created something that's never been done.
I know it's so cool.
Well, I'm glad to have lived a Hollywood life with you,
to be a mom who asks you questions and advice,
to be a "Scream" alumni
and to just be a woman who also is like
the ultimate Courtney Cox fan.
I mean seriously.
Well, I feel the same way
and I will like to see you in person soon.
I hope so too more than anything.
Thank you so much.
And season three of "Nine Months with Courtney Cox"
is out now on Facebook Watch
and new episodes air every Sunday and Thursday
at 5:00 PM, 4:00 PM central.
(upbeat music)